and I'm and this is again one of the
sort of perspective oriented talks sort
of been that in the line of the one that
Helen offered yesterday and the teacher
will offer on Friday and so we're we're
really delighted to have her here
particularly thank you Adam and I'm
delighted to it's I've been a really joy
it the last week and and the first two
weeks of this boot camp II I feel like a
kid in the candy store so many questions
and and fun people to work with and I'll
add a whole bunch of other questions
today from perspective of a service
statistician I will that came across
yesterday I think a few times primarily
talk about surveys but I have a couple
of other heads so this acronym here the
IAB that's the Institute for employment
research in Germany they are a branch of
the basically the German version of the
boroughs Labor Statistics and so I deal
with a lot of administrative data there
as well and the issues of sharing those
now came back to that at the very end
for for some examples - I also want to
thank the artists upstairs in anything
most of you have been on the next floor
and pretty much at this spot there is a
beautiful depiction of campus here and
not just because I had to cut off the
bottom part of the artist's name I also
noticed that I I'm not exactly sure
actually if that was Adele Geoff on
Mount I it's my guess you know okay I
you know you can see that when you
upstairs the two of the characters are
removed I thought that was a
privacy-preserving measure but then the
alternative data source of the Simon's
Institute list of participants in the
fall you know it gave this away so
anyway thanks to Adele I will
shamelessly use this to make my points
here which I have five of that I want to
make I have grouped them into two
categories one sort of points
data collection and designing a data
collection piece and then to around the
data analysis and then I'll talk at the
end as I just mentioned a little bit
about sort of alternative perspectives
the first five points are really all
sort of the the combination of
differential privacy for the kind of
data we deal with and you know we as in
the Statistical agencies and the
research community in the social science
and and so on I love literature in books
that can eventually find their way
upstairs into the talk as well these
ones are very dear to my heart because
that's the reason I'm here I'm Cynthia
and I we both worked for this was partly
two years on a panel of the National
Academy of Science with the goal to a
sort of give guidance directions
thinking about innovations in federal
statistics and you know primarily doing
so with privacy in mind and and we had a
lot of fun but at these two books are
also a very good sort of short summary
easy to read if you want to understand
the lay of that land a little better
okay so let me start with the first
point around data collection and sort of
issues of recruitment and answering
sensitive question which is something
that the survey community has dealt with
a lot and I thought on Monday when I saw
Kobe's talk and this beautiful schema
here I thought oh perfect now I can just
you know point out that we have to think
about the people that create the data as
well and then Sasha yesterday did that
and showed you the sampling but as I
will point out at Sasha and she said it
herself
where are you sorry that they were in
the statistics perspective yesterday
quite some simplifying assumptions on
how the people provide their data and at
the end you had sort of an outlook and
the call out for me to drill down a
little bit and that's what I'm gonna do
so the the first piece I want to mention
and get in your head is sort of on the
data collection side very different to
the data we talked about on Monday
and in particular you guys you know if I
think of data that Google produces or
other big platforms are happening on the
web the data we all deal with are
usually data produced in a fashion that
we beg someone to participate and beg
someone to give us answers right it's
very different it's not the aunt so you
know this schema works well actually for
what we've done on Monday because there
are a lot of situations in what data are
there you know you use the service and
then they and you use it for a different
reason and then it's sort of the
secondary use of the data we're
discussing the situation here is quite
different you know you really want
people to respond and if you want them
to respond to sensitive questions and in
that context actually we have a history
these papers are more recent but the
history of course is way back when
randomized response was my chair should
stop people when randomize response was
you know first discussed the survey
community in the service hasn't jumped
on that because they loved the idea
right let's just give the respondent a
coin and the randomizing device of sorts
and then have them flip the coin and
give them two questions and then the
answer one of them and going on and and
over decades I feel like every decade
there's like a big paper and a big
attempt to do it yet again but it has
never taken off I mean you would think
we ask so many sensitive question but in
the field we have seen it has never
really worked and they were more
recently a couple of studies that really
tried to do this again on the web where
it's a little easier maybe to do the
randomizing device also for more
complicated questions they were a
student of mine anti-creationist she
worked on a study where we have the true
score so we really could compare you
know do people report more sensitive or
not but the biggest problem to this is
it's really hard to explain I mean it
looks like Buddha right you go there and
like flip the coin and then you answer a
question I don't know what the answer
was - and people have troubles you know
so understanding that was a problem but
then also with a limited understanding
comes the problem that you then your
best guess or the your best choice is to
just not reveal the sensitive
information right if you don't know
exactly if it's going to be
but then it's better to say no I did not
smoke marijuana yet last night right or
whatever it is that you were asking and
so so that I have shown that you know in
studies I mean I should say in fairness
if you have resources in a small
research setting or a situation in which
you can really train the interview as
well and you know there you can make it
happen not saying it doesn't work ever
but in large-scale surveys with you know
where you have thousands of interviewers
in the field that's a real challenge
right and and so what we have seen that
in many situations actually if you
establish enough rapport with an
interview that they would understand
this kind of thing there probably is
also a setting in which they would trust
sufficiently to reveal the sensitive
France and so many of these comparative
studies did show that the direct asking
or the direct questioning reveals better
estimate of the truth I I did a a series
of work a while back on sort of other
methods to capture sensitive information
so the the the biggest signal that we
get that removing the interviewer gives
you better rapport is when the survey
field that experiments like we did here
where we randomized people to answer on
the telephone interviewed by an
interviewer on the web without an
interviewer or with an interactive voice
response system also over the phone
right and so these two have no
interviewer and create a more private
mode if you will of reporting and so we
did a study where we also had true
scores from the University of Maryland
administrative record system I mean you
know University records and ask the
alumnus if they drop the class if it got
the D or F and you know with everyone
warning approbation sort of some
somewhat sensitive stuff maybe in well
actually it is sensitive because this is
perceived sensitivity that they report
here but you see that even the perceived
sensitivity is different by mode so as
soon as we remove the interview those
are the lighter dots the perceived
sensitivity is lower for all of these
items but what's also
driver is of course whether you exhibit
that behavior or not right so these
things are not necessarily sensitive for
people who are not subject to that
problem which is always something that
we you know and tend to forget and
obviously the warning or probation was
the most sensitive one but only for
those that were asked by an interviewer
right so it's the interview is the
hurdle but but then what we saw in these
comparison of studies likely is to
randomized responses that that with an
interviewer that explains that you still
have the interviewer present as the
hurdle right so this is not necessarily
helping the way we hope to okay the just
to give you a flavor of sensitive
questions I mean these surveys that the
federal government but also many others
put out they have filled with questions
that you really might you know feel
quite strong about a fantastic example
of a survey that was done on a thing
called active military on sexual assault
of both females and males by Rand and
that report can highly recommend to
anyone but it also shows that with
careful design you get good responses or
trustworthy responses to open-ended
questions and so I don't know if in this
case large-scale on the web you know we
could have for each of these questions
implemented a randomized response
technique right okay so that's on the
data collection side obviously what we
are talking here is doing this post hoc
right but I just want to put that out
there that the trust is a big element in
this and so the Census Bureau has for
years
measured how much people trust the
federal government as data collected and
things like that and in this question
that you see here is data from the
gallup tracking poll where they asked if
people in may respondents to the daily
tracking poll I think that the data are
kept confidential in the Federal
Statistical system and you've seen you
see here that this stayed pretty
constant over time but it is not not up
there I mean they
is already a strong belief across the
board that data is shared across
government agencies even agencies that
don't have an agreement for sharing data
and you know like so so the public
perception on what happens with the data
is already in a strong disconnect to
what's actually going on and so this is
an interesting thing to keep in mind as
we're trying to protect them even more
you know it's like if we can't get that
across then it might not help with the
recruitment if our concern is that
people don't participate right so I mean
if the is the main reason why we want to
fix this problem is that we want to fix
perception then you know it has been a
problem long before so this is 2012
right so long before we have all these
discussions about data sharing yeah sure
absolutely wondering you know is there
differences
leaves from a younger generation in
comparison to Millennials versus an
older generation Facebook generation
yeah yeah yeah the there are definitely
differences across a generation that
differences across the ethnic groups I
don't have the exact percentages in my
head I can look this up the Jennifer
hunter childs gave this presentation in
Barcelona last fall I have a slight egg
it's cleared for public consumption I
mean he does that for the Census Bureau
and we'll check with her if I can post
it to the group and then you can see
those fingers I don't know I'm off the
top of my head but it is the Gallup
track with poll is it's a telephone
survey but they do aim at a well we'll
talk about random samples in moment but
they they aim to at least get landline
and cell phone users and things like
that so it's not it's not a quick online
poll what I've seen in my own research
on for Germany on this day I can speak a
little better to that in particular your
question on data sharing by the
government or private sector companies
among the different generation what
we've clearly seen is that people with a
lot of experience in like using the
technical devices have think even more
that the data will be shared but they
have less concerns right so so this is
very nuanced in all directions but what
what I find interesting he and and work
from Eleanor singer over the years
showed that time and again to that you
know we always make these strong
confidentiality statements at the
beginning of a survey and
despite that you know there's a good
belief that these data will be shared
and in the research she's done actually
showed that if you emphasize that too
much then that harms participation
because then people think their
information is much more sensitive than
it actually is I mean that the risk that
they're engaging in engaging in that
research is actually far greater than
what they thought it is just because I
mean so they experimented they
manipulated these content statement
right and saw that so so the the
messaging is important I guess that's
the short message of this segment
Eleanor singer she did a series of work
I'll post that to the Select group but
you'll find it under her names you out
of the University of Michigan one one
piece of me on messaging that Cynthia
and I talked about last week a little
bit so this sentence up he has clipped
from an invitation to a male survey and
it's very typical for invitations or
advance letters that we send to
respondents your participation is vital
to this effort right we really hone in
that we need people's participation in
that survey right as I said the data
aren't there they just you know that
just happened don't just happen they
they need to be carefully collected and
and that is in some contrast I would say
to this statement here right
and I I can't quite figure out how I
would message that right it's like we
really need you but then whether you
like your data's in there not really
doesn't matter so then you know so so
I'll challenge you you know it to like
if this is jointly a message you know we
should think about how we want to work
this so so one of the research question
in support for this segment here is
really how to communicate now we do we
communicate the methods how do we
establish sufficient trust right in this
whole operation and I can see that maybe
we end up in a place where where you
don't need to understand right unlike
with the randomized Response were in
that moment you need to know maybe if
there's generally the notion that data
is kept saved by everybody in a certain
way that that the trust will happen that
waves like yeah they're sharing data but
nothing can happen right
that's sort of the common norm then
maybe we are good so I'm not saying it's
not possible I'm just saying right now
it's a challenge okay any question to
that piece before I move on yeah so in
the in these content statements often
they do in the experiments we did we
always address the sender so shared with
the researcher shared for commercial
purposes but not necessarily as
fine-tuned as it would be necessary to
really hit all your parameters I would
say okay so moving on to the dirty
business of data collection I indicated
you know data just don't just happen and
and what I find careful when they you
know we talk about a survey statistic to
think about the two steps that go in
there to get the inference right and
they're really two steps of inference
Sasha was talking yesterday about this
step here getting to the target
population and made sort of a leap of
faith saying most samples are simple
random samples which I will contest in a
second but the the the other piece is
that it's really not the inference step
as well which is on the measurement side
right the response we get is not
necessarily always exactly our construct
and a good example for that is always
sort of crime statistic you know the
national crime and victimization survey
is a very important survey very
expensive survey and in you could you
know naively says like okay well
reported crime if I want to measure that
I you know we have crime reports in
administrative data and can get it from
there but you really need in surveys to
ask both reported crime so that you can
then ask the unreported crime and we
know that they are for certain crimes
there's quite a big difference between
the two so you can't rely on these
administrative data alone and and that's
something that in this panel I mentioned
at the beginning we discussed at links
right while they are exciting other data
sources to describe what happens in
society by themselves they often are not
sufficient you you for many research
questions we have over public policy
questions we need to augment it with the
survey data so that this combination of
different data sources just no way
around at least for now
so here you see the measurement
instrument that would be implemented in
the survey is already you know sort of
you know yeah it is correlated with the
construct we are interested in but it's
not quite that right I need to define a
time frame I need to you know sort of
get more specific on what I mean with
crime and things like that so this is
already a first era source here the
validity of what how I phrase that
question in the actual construct I want
so this is a leap and there's already I
mean that you can hope that's highly
correlated but that's the hardest one to
measure but then of course on the next
step getting the respondents answer you
know in some instances might be pretty
easy and you you think there's a good
mapping but in other instances not so
much they brought a little audio clip of
what what a woody test a wooden clap
yeah what
[Music]
you work the city then choices are
totally paper somewhat paper
oh yeah they were somebody's about to
not strongly opposed to wait best
English to anyway but I bastard all the
time correct I mean I just want to be
clear on the language that I mean you
think you the client what you know dude
this is not really Thank You Tamara so I
gave her that this is the reality of
data collection right no I mean I cut it
up I mean they were continuing the
conversation but so there are two people
really trying to get it right right one
may be reading the phone while on the
phone or something right some slightly
distracted respondent and an interview
he does exactly what he needs to do
right he gets this somewhat but he needs
to know is this somewhat favor post not
making inference ask again but then not
explained too much because he or she
shouldn't put in their own bias to this
so this is a this is pretty typical you
know and so I I felt like it's important
to expose you to that a little bit it's
it's so easy to like when once the data
are there you know they have they're
just data but there's a cognitive
process going on here and there has been
over the years quite some sorry quite
some literature on sort of mapping out
potential sources for this measurement
error right so cognitive shortcuts
people do you know how heuristics when
they're here you know but what is clear
is that whatever you know your responses
you know it's hopefully the truth school
plus some error and
then you know there might be the
assumption that this is random but in
just noise in some sort and it could be
to some extent in this case here next
time you call this respondent you might
get a slightly different answer so over
iterations we can't necessarily be sure
with these answer categories but if it's
a good measurement then we hope that
Sigma is zero but there are biases of
course that that happen and one needs to
take into account so this you know it's
a bit of work in some instances this
another error source coming in through
post-processing when when in particular
it senses there's a huge editing
operation going on inconsistencies
between answers that get removed and
things like that so open questions for
me here with respect to sort of what
what we are doing here is they showed
you the response burden is quite high
for some of these things I mean if you
listen in to questions on sort of labor
market histories and trying to
reconstruct where when did you work for
how much money what did you buy you know
it gets really tedious and the Consumer
Expenditure survey if you want to go
through what you put out the last months
in the last three months you know hey we
can hook you up with some interviewers
to experience that life it gets really
tedious to remember all of this remember
what you paid for it how much tax you
paid for it and whatnot so the the hope
really is there to link this to other
data sources to administrative data
sources that have they the employment
records to you know your a no credit
card or what have you
just to make that that rest of the data
collection easier and better right so I
think the attempt is there and what
we've seen over the years playing with
requests on data linkage is that there
is actually quite a substantial
villainess of those sort of use
respondents to have their data linked
right even without it I mean in the
normal set of privacy assurances that we
do there but what is interesting in in
so the this this paper here that just
talks and I
wrote if you use ago shows sort of
linkage concentrates across it many
different fields in the studies we do in
Germany we often get up to 80 or 90
percent consent although only for those
who already consented to do the survey
right I mean there's a little bit of a
trade-off here to keep in mind but this
research line of research also shows
that there is quite some difference in
these statements depending on how I
asked when I asked and what purpose I'm
saying how I phrase it so that a
challenging question for me to think
through is this one here so given that I
just showed you this measurement error
in the responses right it's not clear to
me how we treat that in the peer setting
right because like okay well you know
maybe I'm like 0.8 really in the one
category and then the other point two of
my answer really would belong to zero so
there is some randomness in that process
can I should I do I have to you know
account for that randomness in the
answer process when I create the
differentiate private data right and if
so you know to which extent right I mean
that's what do I ignore that but then I
make them fix and then I cement in error
that otherwise we would you know try to
fact outs like that that's sort of an
interesting puzzle to me another puzzle
to me is if we if someone in this
response process maybe to the sensitive
questions that we showed you before
decides to not answer or decides to give
me a false information and now I'm going
in and with our great latent variable
malas and whatever have we right we
impute data or we you know also the data
in some way that the true value is now
in because that was the best predictor
and that I mean we actually know your
answer given everything else and
whatever else said then then then we are
taking agency away from the respondent
who just tried to give me wrong
information right so not clear to me
here maybe you guys thought about this
already but for me that's a sort of a
puzzle as I was trying to see what what
this data collection process how that
might be affected but what we do here
okay so that's on the the measurement
side moving on or maybe I should pause
here for a second - a thing
I see you nodding heads for now alright
moving on to the to the other side of
that graph here on the representation
side so we had yesterday you know you
define your population that's fine you
have hopefully a sampling frame that
helps you get the addresses that you you
need or you know collect the data that
you need but with many of the frames we
do have already an error here you know
which we call coverage era I mean
there's really a data source that allows
us to to actually I only know of the
Netherlands as being a having a
beautiful solution to this problem here
because they define the target
population as everyone who is on the
sampling frame so when I once asked it
was like how do you deal with elegant
you know illegal immigrants you know
they're not on your population register
and they say well we don't care we make
inference to who is on the population
register so that's it right that that's
a beautiful trick to get rid of that
coverage error but for everything else
you you kind of have that problem
already I we heard yesterday that once
we have the sampling frame that we we
deal with you know sampling error and
sampling variance but the the one piece
that we also heard was you know quote
unquote most samples are let's assume
that samples are simple random sample
now like this what the graph you see
here is a pretty important survey done
by the University of Michigan since 1959
on consumer sentiment so every months
they ask 500 people how they see you
know economy growing and this data is
used by you know Federal Reserve Board I
think they even pay for that data
collection and to pity I mean makes the
news every time they come out right and
so my question to is like if you try to
get a sentiment of the economy from 500
people in the US a drannit how would you
how would you do that
phone numbers phone numbers okay phone
numbers so where do you get the phone
number
exactly the phone work great and so so
phone on the phone you might be there's
no phone book right so we generate
numbers at random their phone banks you
know which portions of phone numbers are
used so that you don't dial you know
into nothing plus you need to know how
many of the ones you tried actually
responded so there's a big whole
machinery to even get that right but
that's the closest we would come to a
simple random sample and then you still
have a problem that it's particular
interviewers doing an interview and I
show you in a moment why that is a
problem so very good point this is you
have been hanging out with repair to
we're going on too long because that was
exactly his point why he is like let's
let's move to the online world and you
know measure consumer prices and what
have you on the online world that's you
know always done the same it reflects
the offline world so there are
workarounds I'm not saying you can't do
proxies the I there are certainly other
ways to do this I would agree
the the fallback on random samples is
the hope for a safeguard to really
capture you know the mixture that we
have in the population right and that
you don't that that not all in a certain
subgroups you don't think about develop
a different perspective and you don't
capture it right and that's why a random
sample it doesn't need to be a simple
random sample but that's why a random
sample and it doesn't work the reason
why I point out the simple random sample
piece is only because everything every
formula sasha showed yesterday for which
there is already a DP solution in doing
hypothesis testing for which there's
already a DP solution for regression
what have you what have you they all
assume that it is a send a random sample
and what I'm saying is in practice
because they are so hard we hardly ever
do ever into a simple random sample so
what we do instead I saw your hand just
a second what we do instead are
that we call in a multi-stage transfer
cluster you know a whole bunch of other
things but for those we don't have DP
solutions yet so even you know
hypothesis testing in that sense it's
not solved for survey data because the
sampling structure is not correctly
reflected and that has huge consequences
for the yeah so this this this is a mix
of these two techniques so we go back to
the same people twice but then they
asked that new people so it's a over the
years always a new set of people that
come in so yeah also that theoretically
right the pure theories that menu
especially people here more interested
in that the statistical Theory relies in
simple
a simple random sample right and of
course we have a good theory for for non
iid situations some sets and some
settings but already we will display
extracted by clustering there are some
from design prospective solutions in
terms of how your conference the
variability in variants and how you
perhaps feel this with models not like
oh I know exactly the central limit
theorem and it's unique in all the
settings like what I talked about
already he already called remember I
said yes we simplify theoretical
perspective does not exist in many many
of these study exactly and so so um just
allowing everyone to catch up what we
mean risk stratified and clustered
because I realize I too can have
technical terms that no one understands
so when we say stratified we mean you
know you divide your population up in
sort of distinct sets of people either
geographically or you know by
characteristics on what have you and
then you sample out of these different
strata and the reason you do this that
effect this will have it it will reduce
your variance right because from if you
think of random samples out of this
right you can sometimes end up with just
read or just blue or just circles and
just squares and you know what have you
so much higher chance for variability
and here where you know that you have a
fixed proportion you can you know know
ahead of time what that is in in cluster
sample it's a little different
cluster samples you you you basically
just have subgroups right and and you do
that often in combination with these so
let me give you an example in this
national crime and victimization service
because they try to make estimates for
the entire country right they you would
stratify the country by States or by
northeast Southwest you know whatever
like regional strata and then within
that you would want to have a random
sample but how do you do that that
survey is done face to face so an
interview comes to your house that would
be huge travel cost if you have imagined
a population register from which we
could sample addresses right and have
all people but then they still I mean it
would take forever to get to all these
places and would cost a ton so what they
do instead they they have multiple
rounds of going from you know a launch
area to smaller areas and then go you
know to one town or one neighborhood and
do all this of the the interviews there
so then it's clustered geographically
right so that's that's what happens in
pretty much all surveys that are done in
face-to-face what this does is it
increases your variance by a lot right
because then you have people who live
closer together they are inevitably a
little more similar right they can
afford the same houses they you know
exposed to the same crime and
what-have-you right but even on the
phone surveys that I mentioned before we
actually have clustering going on
because of the interviewer right so the
interviewers - they have their own way
of talking to you right their own way of
appearing and we have seen in countless
research studies that that does affect
the answers and makes the answers of the
respondents more similar to each other
than they would be otherwise and so so
that's that's a huge problem so this the
the clustering piece as I said enlarges
our standard error meaning makes our
confidence in the most lanza so you know
here's an example where we use data from
the piece of study the OECD study that
measures you know math achievement and
language achievement across you know in
lots of countries and here's the
difference between Denmark in the u.s.
on on on thinking taking the correct
sample design of the survey into account
versus not so here's the point estimate
for Denmark and in Denmark you know
small country not so much going on I
mean the probably voice is imperative
sampling the P I did this a herself but
but in the US you know you have a huge
sampling design effect so that if you
use the correct standard error a test of
the difference between those two would
say there's no difference between the
u.s. and
in Denmark whereas if you use the
incorrect senator is the simple random
sample isn't standard errors you would
think that there is a difference that is
significant between these two and that's
the problem and that's why it's so
important to like any you know reports
that come out any theories that are
tested that that you take the sample
design into account and that means when
we do this DP we also have to take it
into account is it the case that for the
commonly used sample designs it's sort
of very easy to do this adjustment or
you know very easy meaning it's sort of
the methodology is well-established you
take a class it's pretty clear everybody
would agree on what the right adjustment
is yeah yeah so for many techniques that
is the case although it you would be
astonished and I have a reference I
think a couple of slides down it's still
not used you know I mean so some
colleagues of mine and the foremost
reason they did take a survey of papers
published in like you know the tier 1
economics and medical journals and
whatnot I mean it's how many just
ignored it they report on simple random
sample standard errors when they do
their modeling right so yes agreed upon
shrimp use not necessarily but it's not
I mean it's not I mean by now we are
pretty far along with techniques but I
would still say there are plenty of
statistical modeling techniques where
that is not developed yet but for for
the the the the most most of them yes
and part I mean you don't necessarily so
close form solutions have been developed
for some for others you can model it in
a different way now come back to that in
a in a moment and maybe that could be a
direction for to a solution for here
yeah I guess one of my questions is sort
of about to what extent is there judge a
judgment call and involved on the part
of the analyst where they have to decide
oh well I'm gonna model you know these
this this this population is uniform or
stretched you know like to what extent
is the person analyzing
have to make kind of choices yeah I the
usually the proper weights you know and
some of this is captured through
replicate weights we'll talk about in a
moment are provided by those that create
the data so an informed analyst uses
that and then it should come out for
everybody in the same way
so there's if you know the sample design
of your study and you pay attention to
it then you can do it right then there's
little analyst choice left at that point
yeah linking vena that Jimmy did outside
of surveys to survey's um about that in
which respect yeah I'll say a few things
to that yep yeah okay so another point I
want to make aside from the cost that we
have here sort of for statistical
precision right I I do thought it might
be a good thing it might be helpful to
tell you that these surveys also cost a
lot of money so you know it face to face
half-hour interview in the US easily
cost a thousand dollars a case so now
you take a survey that has 30,000
respondents so if you feel an outcry of
people messing with the carefully
crafted precisely measured measurements
and you say I made a little bit of noise
you know which basically shrinks your
sample size which means you have to
collect more data it really costs it
hurts you know and that's part of the
reason why people are quite sensitive
about that I mean the all this machinery
all the statistical development and
getting the Senators right and coming up
with fancy sampling techniques to reduce
the variance and reduce the variance is
not to then they don't on a fter what's
come in and at no way since ii just
collect a few more cases right so that
you can do that maybe on the mail you
know
sufficiently cheaper but not as good
right so how high quality government
survey data they are still have a strong
face-to-face component I mean they're
struggling as it is to keep the money
for the surveys the response it gets
expensive every year in a more expensive
because response rates are increasing
and things like that but this is this is
just something sort of it in the back of
your mind as you talk with practitioners
you know there's a real value to that in
time as well of course more sample means
much more time needs to be invested to
collect the data all right so we talked
a little bit about adjustment obviously
non-response not everyone responds right
so we have another arrow source that
comes in to that we tend to model to
your question as they agreed upon way to
do this so there's agreed-upon way on
how you adjust for the sample design
right so clustering is stratification
and there's different the unequal
weighting probabilities
that's nailed down I would say by and
large much less clear what's the proper
way to do non-response adjustment in
part because we need outside data we
need census data you know as benchmarks
or other sources where we can really
know okay these are the people we're
missing and that's how we are waiting
our data in order to remove any bias
from people who do not participate okay
I have a short audio clip here just to
sort of show you the recruitment
challenge we basically 500 household
each month and this is just to hone in
the point interviewers do play a role
right so even if you think you have a
simple random sample no clustering the
interviewers very
so much in their voices you know we did
Studies on their vocal properties and
predicting the probability to recruit
people into the sample they're quite
some I mean there's an optimal speed
there's an optimal number of pauses and
ohms and arms you know to say to do the
recruitment so that means they
selectively sample into the study
already through the way they work but
then also in the inaction with the
respondent you know they they do tend to
create clustering effects so so that's
certainly something to pay attention to
so in summary for this segment here
question is how do we get unbiased
estimates using DP what sample size do
we need what does that mean really if we
have a certain you know level of
precision we try to to reach what can we
do to take the violation of iid into
account you know violated by having
interviewers violated by having long at
you know data violated by interviewing
households rather than individuals which
is also something that we do quite often
to save time I mean type of money
actually and and then if you know if
they were a situation where we have
limited access due to a privacy budget
of course a question that comes up in
the discussions that I have is I can we
justify all these costs you know if if
then the public good is somewhat limited
in this excess afterwards right so
that's another thing that people do
worry about okay I promised to talk a
little bit about the analysis side as
well but we covered a little bit of it
here one thing I thought might be useful
to remind us here is that the research
question the social scientists ask they
have really general and they are really
I mean we could have a whole nother
conversation on what's good science
right and I don't want to go there but
let's just assume the science they do
and the science they would like to
continue to do would need to be done
with data and DP so these are I clipped
those from you know good journals in
this respective fields you know the key
search questions that they ask you know
what I've seen sort of published this
month and and you can see it the way
these questions are formulated leaves a
lot of room for analysts choices so to
your point Adam right not so much on the
correct variance estimation but pretty
much for everything else right in what
is interesting is that for many of these
questions even the methodology used to
later on analyze the data is not
necessarily clear ahead of time right
I mean you if you look at the different
fields they have the typical methods
right so if psychologists you know if
they do their own experiment they they I
already gave it away right they go in
and with the notion of I do experiments
if not then you know they use ANOVA type
methods economists would usually use
some version of regression a time series
analysis depending on what data you deal
with in sociology in related fields you
see a lot of multi-level random effect
models demography has a lot of time to
invent models and and we could now you
know spent the next two months going is
for all of these you know and their
respective assumptions and in where the
arrow sign I hope you didn't think I
would give that kind of talk here
because that would have been impossible
to do all right but I I'm happy to sort
of pick some you know to the extent
there's interest to look a little deeper
into methods used for these fields but
to get an idea of the the process and
workflow of data analysis in these field
is they're using these methods and
they're using them on data most often
provided by someone else through these
data archives right icpsr has a big data
archive there's one in the UK one in
Germany and you know many many more and
then they go in you know with a very
broad research question and the data
they have there and then there is you
know a large exploratory portion to it
and you see it even in the published
papers right so apologize for that I
could it would never put that in a talk
for the purpose here it will serve our
needs if you can't read this at the end
these are the multi low it's a
multi-level model sociology
no sort of psychology variance between
countries within a country this is the
European social survey that they used
and then a linear regression model they
try to estimate risk factors for
depression among immigrants and ethnic
minorities and compare that to the rest
so this is the these are the two burials
of most interesting and they try to
adjust for a whole bunch of other
variables age and you know where they
live and some some employment status
variables and what you often see in
these journals is so they have their
first model and then they include a few
more variables and a few more and sort
of see what happens and so the this
exploratory Nietzsche's is very much
part of how data is analyzed which makes
it hard you know if you have a situation
where you're upfront need to tell
someone this is the analysis I'm gonna
do these are the various that I'm gonna
need and in and get your you know
private data that way right so so then
that I don't think that that this will
work so then you know then the model
selection is unclear the you know the
the strong reliance on focus on standard
errors to guide some of these choices is
a problem the very large mix of
categorical and continuous variables is
an interesting challenge in these models
if we think about that and and of course
the complex data structure that I
mentioned before in the multi-level
model and last but not least the so in
this study here they actually found a
few outliers in their model and then
went after these I mean not literally
they didn't go after these respondents
but they look much closer and drilled
even further down in the data set to
learn what's going on here and I see
this a lot that the discovery app
actually happens in the data analysis
and that triggers the next study right
or even you know teams of researchers
that didn't pay up and someone goes out
and does qualitative interviews with
those outliers to see what's going on
and what can be learned right so if you
can't get to the outliers anymore you
don't know who they really are or not
their whole set of characteristics then
then that piece of discovery is closed
right yeah
so this sort of drilling down adaptive
process to what extent is this okay
statistically speaking yeah so that's -
things like we can have another
discussion whether this is good science
right so I have a little opinion piece
that I started writing on sort of okay
well if we if we have social signs that
embrace DP right maybe that makes all of
us better people right in the sense that
in the sense that we would up from
specify exactly what we want to do you
know before we collect the data and
we're really clear and then we just run
this one model and we pre-register what
we plan on doing and then we you know
grant it that could be a version right
all I'm presenting here that's
absolutely not how it's done right now
right and so if this I mean
Gianna's are pretty good and reuse are
pretty good and sort of pointing out
issues of multiple testing and it's just
in your standard errors when you do that
too much in things like that so there is
awareness of that problem in depending
on the quality of the journal it's done
more or less right but but I thought it
might be useful for you just to sort of
know that that's how they work with the
data right I mean I'm not saying this is
how we should work with the data forever
I'm just saying currently in order to
understand why there there are
communications problems in convincing
another idea you know they feel a threat
that this kind of working with the data
is not possible since you did you had a
question
yeah don't want to put you on this yeah
so it exactly so that's the point I made
earlier so that this disadvantage of you
know I mean yesterday Sascha made us a
couple of times I mean I love it from
the perspective that we are basically
forcing all of us to embrace robust
statistics right so I think that's an an
excellent and a very important point
right and in and so I'm absolutely with
you that was the first version of this
talk right and then I thought well wait
a second I mean I need to tell you sort
of what the concerns are on the other
end you know I'm with you that that can
be a good thing but certain elements
here for example this interest in
outliers you know and a certain element
of discovery is then still not possible
right and so so while I see you often
you know a sensitivity analyses done and
eventually you know I mean so the the
the data analysis is really quite
iterative process in tasks almost a
design aspect to it if you will right
because people try out a lot of things
with the data before it gets published
if often ends up being then you know yes
now we use the robust statistic model or
now we you know they constrain ourselves
in other ways but there's a lot of
learning going on with the data itself
and you know looking at particular cases
outliers as I said and so that that's an
element I think that that we need to
take serious and in mostly because it's
so expensive to get to the data in the
first place
right right so yeah so so I'm with Steve
on that and that's I mean I I had an
email exchange with my I'm not gonna say
with whom but anyway I you know I
mentioned that I'm giving this talk and
showed this opinion piece where I say
well this is this could be a blessing
for for the Social Sciences because
they're forced to do robust statistics
if we do DP right and in but his
response was basically along the lines
of well this is the end of science
because the real interesting thing
happens in the outliers and in that
discovery process right and so okay well
thanks for brother strong opinion but
you know that the point is and we've
seen this in other places too I mean the
point is if we want to get we want to
move forward right we have to have that
conversation you have to bring people on
board right and in one concern and
that's so thank you for pointing that
out one concern that I have heard and
that's my list of questions here you
know is can I do
can I still work with the data in the
way I'm used to and you know if the
answer already is for some of it yes
great right to the extent we fix the
standard error pot but but if you know
for certain elements it's not and then
it's good to know what those are I'm
also trying to understand sort of how
interest can be in out layers let me try
to tell this story that I'm just sort of
making up right now and see if maybe
this is part of it which is I when you
look at the outliers obviously you miss
a lot of things that could have been in
the outliers but aren't there right
obviously a lot of times you see
something that's actually not a
statistical significance but in many
cases you don't have a big enough sample
to be doing this sense that you want to
be hurting and so looking at the
outliers
you sometimes see sometimes useful hints
if some other data you should have
gathered or some other question you
should have asked and so looking at the
outliers if even though it doesn't have
sort of statistical significance in our
usual sense it can sometimes be useful
in guiding the future of science that's
how I would characterize it that's what
I would I would characterize it and and
I do think that this argument is
somewhat short-sighted you know because
it if you have enough data and you have
enough signal with the outliers you will
still see that after DP the starting
point is you don't have enough data
right where if you you know absolutely
if like you know in a future scenario
where all the admin data and all the
tech data are DP and we can get them and
then we can add survey data to it you
know somehow and have much fewer survey
data and can learn I mean they can be a
beautiful new data world out there for
the social scientists researchers that I
can envision and that's why I'm here and
like to work on it but the we we can't
we if we want to march that way I think
it is important to just be aware of what
the concerns are and understand that you
know just pointing to a larger sample
size you know some of that does not
necessarily cut it as an argument for
the reasons I gave before because
launched a sensor size is really
expensive right and so yeah so I guess
the short answer is yes seems like what
you're trying to do the outliers
under DDP but more like information flow
like the talk yesterday so for the
outliers you actually want to control
that flow in some sense but you want to
see how far they go yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah you want to see the
raw data I just want to point to a
couple of other points before it went
have the clock in mind but just yeah
been purely interactive and there have
been lots of questions I think it'd be
fine to take a little more time all
right good how much not not too much but
I I have a few more sides yeah I mean
well ten minutes ten minutes we'll be
out here in ten minutes no but so so so
yes to your point I think that that this
is a way to think about it and they
could be other ways to get back to the
raw data and have that information flow
and discovery without a doubt is as I
said I none of these points I make here
you know our arguments with which I
think I would want to shut that
operational that's not that's not the
role I'm playing here right I just want
to make that clear the though there are
a couple of situations so in which and
we've discussed this in the intro talk
on Monday where DP is you know not or I
mean I don't know if the answer is never
will or not yet there but in you know in
the survey data collection well it has
to become pretty pretty popular and you
know reasonable you know similar to the
medical field to work in a responsive
way right where you're like based on the
data you have you sort of learned you
build a predictive model on what's the
probability to get next responding and
what's the probability of that
respondent to actually give you more
information into the sample is that
someone who is just like everyone you
have and therefore you don't need to go
after that person right so this requires
linkage of different data sets but it
also requires a predictive model in
which you want to act on right and
obviously policymakers that would want
to use data they they want to do
interventions or what have you and would
have the same problem right so this is
this is not exactly outlier but it's
sort of
in a similar vein that you want to know
something exactly about a case and want
to you know act upon whether it's
reinter viewing that person to
understand whether they gave you wrong
answers and therefore are weird or you
know re-interview and learn more about
their life or if you want to act in an
intervention kind of way would would be
sort of similar settings yeah what's
their question here because and this is
maybe abstractionists for the rest of
the semester if you are the owner of the
database like you are an insider in the
IRS or an insider in the census and you
perform some computation on the data
that isn't easy and you learn something
about the data that you cannot publish
but you think it's a significant finding
and I think this is yeah this is very
much related so so I think we have ways
of coping with those things we have to
do I think that language to describe
these different and I use the term
threat analysis
yeah no I think you're writing and this
is exactly what sort of end up here I do
think they're different scenarios and
different types of data that require a
different means right I mean obviously I
mean if you if you have a scenario where
no one ever gets to the raw data and
this is not possible right but what
you're describing is they could be
settings in which at least for sort of
the day a clean up part and what have
you you still have access to the raw
data and you can do that right and and
so then it depends on sort of the
complexity of the research questions and
how that's organized I mean it's a it's
a different type of problem a different
nature of a problem but yeah absolutely
okay so clear I mean in any other
setting this would clearly kill the talk
and the conversation here I'm not so
sure but I mean they're there one more
book for the library in the in the in
the variance estimation in in bias
correction afterwards I promised you
that I talked about that for a moment
just want to give sort of a hint here on
the different approaches that we do in
order to like in on the analysis side in
order to take the complex sample design
structure into account and so there's
one set here you know for linear
estimators you have exact they're exact
formulas that take that sampling
structure into account when you don't
have that most of the time or very
popular for a long time we're solving
this we are tailored linearization so
that that has been very popular what's
done more and more I'd say at least by
the more sophisticated data collectors
is you know applying what we call
replicate weights right and replicate
weights basically means that you divide
you know you're your full sample into
sub samples of replication and then you
repeat the weighting computation for
each sub sample and that includes the
base weight the adjustments the the
any calibration you did in order to
account for non-response and things like
that and you include all the information
on stratification and clustering and so
these these replicate weights in
basically our one way that can be done
by the data provider right that that
captured sort of the complex nature of
the the survey and they're now used in
the analysis so I haven't thought this
through but that could be one route in
which this is then possible in dpi have
to think more about that another piece
that I hear is concern with the census
moves the way it's planning to move is a
lot of surveys in particular the smaller
ones in particular the ones that don't
rely necessarily on a very careful
collected random sample they need these
data for non-response adjustment the
popular method is the general regression
estimator to do that where you have
basically two portions in there you have
your survey data and I mean the inputs
weighed from your survey and then a
vector of population totals that you get
from the sensors or other places and I I
mean the American Community Survey is a
very very popular data source for that
and so it might still be possible and
they might already have thought about
all these secondary uses of the data but
but that's something that I heard people
say they're getting very nervous about
like is this still sufficiently workable
then as source for adjusting for all
these other surveys right so that's
there's something to keep in mind from
all I first off I think the answers yes
but you know just want to put that out
there for discussion so on the the this
part of the analysis side replicates
weights and DP that would be an
interesting thing to find out the
population then benchmark pieces you
know more and more as people are
concerned whether they have biases in
the data is an important one and then
the the Sasha you mentioned that
yesterday that that you know if they're
out is synthetic data and in particular
that route allowing sort of working with
data more interactively right then then
I mean you already listed all the open
questions in that space so I think I'm
looking forward to that discussion I do
think there's a lot of Merit if people I
make think people can get the hitter
easily around the synthetic data way of
working with data but then if I
understood you correctly we haven't
figured out the variance estimation for
that necessarily either okay all right
well lots to learn for me in that space
okay so on the last minute that I
promised I mean how here the example I
wanted to come back to just to give you
a sense of what type of data linkage we
often face and have in so at the
Institute for employment research a
typical set of administrative data that
we have our Social Security
Administration records so every day of
employment and you know the type of job
you have and your salary to the day and
that for the last 70 72 I think we have
the research base at hand so you know
for anyone in post employed in Germany
or gainfully employed in Germany we have
these data and that these data are
already linked to a survey data so to
answer your question here sort of these
linkage rates really are you know as
high as 80 90 percent because people who
participate in this span you know
there's like okay well this I'm already
I mean participating in research study
there's no hesitation than to add more
data to this research process the the
other way around you know we're you know
I mean that the legislation on what
linkage requests need to be asked is
varies widely and actually after GDP our
it has gotten a little easier for the
research community in Germany to link
data and not harder surprisingly but but
that is a different story but you know
to your question of an example so that
would be a typical setting and what we
have just recently done is linked that
you know people who were in in the
combination of these two data you know
asked them to
participate in a smartphone study that
is not unlike you know I don't know
people read the news last night not
unlike the research apps that travel
they use right now you know pretty much
access to anything the phone convention
and yes I mean the content statements
here is nothing we would have ever
gotten through a German IRB board we had
during the onboarding process at least
you know seven other pages of content
that people have to actively opt into
and read and you know we've measured the
time they read and I mean a big endeavor
to make sure we know people were exposed
to the content but but then the question
we get is like so internally to your
point Helen internally we can analyze
these data easily right but of course
this is this is such an expensive
endeavor I mean all these data sources
cost a lot of money and other
researchers want to analyze the data and
so for us the questions like how can we
how can we give that to someone else
right I mean a completely chaotic data
structure the launch administrative data
structure I mean a chaotic but complex
right the survey data over ten years
penal wave and then all of the sensor
measures from the phone I don't know
right I mean can I like can I make these
available through DPA tomorrow probably
not right and so but that's what people
ask us now and so you know the the often
populated solutions and Daniel works
with Julia Lane on projects and kindly
funded projects like that is to create
researcher spaces you know in which the
those data can be housed and analyzed by
people who are vetted and output that's
controlled and you mentioned these
research data centers yesterday right
the question though in all these models
is where you know you have a safe
environment and and then you work inside
this given the complexity of the data
you do wanna in the launch interest in
it
how can we scale it so I think there are
a lot of interesting computer science
and theoretical form also on that side
it's like could be autumn eyes that
whole process can I automatically check
if someone writes codes that would
violate can I automatically you know
look at the output in run-on I know that
some people who are here working on that
L
so that's why I thought I throw that up
as an additional route that is sort of
for the now and immediate also an
important problem to solve because the
the the owners are institutes like the
IME that have you know helps that have
the the data of the type that that I
described they want to share and they
just need to find a vehicle to do so I
[Music]
think given the time we'll take the
further discussion offline for the next
months over that you know will resume on
time